I'm so thankful working with my best
friend Sheena chicka-chicka
best friends that make music together
stay together I feel like I gave birth
in a way you know to a child but it's a
musical child ariana grande dropped a
new single Monday called monopoly here's
what you need to know the song features
Ahri's best friend Victoria Monet the
girls co-wrote the track and have a long
history of writing together from Ari's
first album all the way through recent
hits like thank you next and 7 rings the
monopoly music video was co-directed by
two members of Ari's inner circle her ex
Ricky Alvarez and videographer Alfredo
Flores it's basically a super fabulous
Instagram story
lots of selfie style BTS footage a ton
of emojis and even an appearance from
viral sensation Dante Kohli who's famous
for inspirational videos like this
[Music]
as for the monopoly lyrics they're
getting a lot of buzz especially this
one
one more time fans are wondering if the
song is our ease way of coming out is
bisexual
one Twitter user wrote Arianna ain't
gotta label herself she replied I
haven't before and still don't feel the
need to now which is ok do whatever you
want whatever you want whatever feels
natural for yourself
the song also gives a shout-out to our
ease vocal coach the time they drank too
much champagne at Tiffany's and wrote 7
rings and they even poked fun at that
expensive sound of music sampling 7
rings it's a very honest album and yeah
it feels like the next version of me
feels like there's a step forward still
me
[Music]